nos preguntan cuál es la altura del
girasol pausa el vídeo y piénsalo bien
veamos el inicio del girasol está
alineado con la parte inferior de la
regla así que la regla está en el lugar
indicado ahora el girasol sube hasta
este punto justo aquí así que este
girasol mide 1 2 3 4 5 y un poquito más
así que tendremos una fracción cuál es
la cantidad exacta bueno podemos ver que
el espacio entre 5 y 6 está dividido en
cuatro partes iguales tenemos una dos
tres cuatro o podemos ver que dividieron
el espacio con estas pequeñas marcas en
uno dos tres
cuatro secciones iguales el girasol
llega a la primera de estas secciones
iguales entre 5 y 6 entonces este
girasol mide 5 pies y un cuarto aquí
tenemos comunidades los pies que se
simbolizan como ft muy bien hagamos otro
ejemplo aquí nos preguntan que lápiz
mide 2 pulgadas y tres cuartos pausa el
vídeo e intenta pensar la respuesta y
recordemos el símbolo de la pulgada es
muy bien vamos a movernos una pulgada
dos pulgadas y después tenemos que
pensar en dónde se encuentra tres
cuartos entre dos y tres para pensar en
tres cuartos tenemos que dividir la
parte de la regla que está entre dos y
tres en cuatro secciones iguales así que
veamos si los dividimos de esta forma
tenemos dos secciones iguales ahora si
tomamos cada una de estas dos secciones
iguales y las dividimos entre dos
tenemos cuatro secciones iguales entre 2
y 3 observa uno dos tres cuatro
secciones iguales entonces si pensamos
en tres cuartos queremos ir hasta tres
de estas cuatro secciones iguales 1 2 3
y entonces podemos ver justo aquí que
tenemos a dos y tres cuartos y también
podemos ver que el lápiz
es el que mide justo eso